[موسيقى]
ربما يعتقد العديد من الليبيين انه هو تم
منعي من الحكومه الولايه او من المجموعات
المسلحه ولكن هذا غير صحيح
الامم المتحده لم تعترف بالخطوه لقام بها
مجلس الدوله
والبرلمان واعترفت بي يعني في البدايه
كرئيس وزراء ولكنها لم تعترف بالحكومه
والشككت في مصداقيه التصويت مع انه هو تم
تسجيله بالكامل يعني بالصوت والصوره
واعتبر انا عدم تمكن حكومتي من الدخول
لطرابلس بسبب عدم اعتراف الامم المتحده
[موسيقى]
اولا في الاتفاق اللي تم في جنيف هي هذه
الحكومه مدتها سنه تقود ليبيا للانتخابات
وتنتهي في شهر 12
واقصى مده لها كوعاء زمني بعد اجراء بعد
البدءات الانتخابات هو شهر سته حتى يتم
تسليم والاستلام ما بين البرلمان القديم
والجديد وايضا
انتخاب الرئيس وانت الرئيس بانتخب رئيس
وزراء هذه كلها تحتاج الى حوالي اربعه الى
سته اشهر ولكن ايضا انتهت شرعيته
والبرلمان سحب منا الثقه فالشرعيه الليبيه
هو يعني ما عندهاش اي شرعيه ليبيه ومنتهيه
حكومه بالكامل بالنسبه الشرعيه الليبيه
القانونيه هو اللي خلاه يستقوى ربما هو
يعني اعتراف المجتمع الدولي به
[موسيقى]
والله بالنسبه لي شخصين نبدا بنفسي انا
يعني محسوب على دوره فبرايره وانا من دورت
فبراير ودفعت فيها تم غالي سته من من
عائلتي من اجل ماذا من اجل الحكم الدم
الديمقراطي والتداول السلمي على السلطه
بينما دبيبه نقول لك هذا رئيس الحكومه
المتاهيه غير مقتنع بالحكم الديمقراطي وهو
يضحك على الناس وشفناه انتم
حرام عليك الانتخابات يعني شماعه بيعلق
هو هو يريد الاستمرار هو وعائلته للابد
هذا برنامجهم وهو لما يقول النبي نبي نسلم
الحكم انتخابي باعتبار انه يقعد في السلطه
ويقدم احد الاشخاص الاخرين من عائلتها
يتقدم انتخابات
[موسيقى]